Wie bitte ja es stimmt tatsächlich in los angeles werden jetzt die straßen weiß
Gestrichen um das hitzeproblem der stadt ein zudem ob das klappen wird
Und noch viele weitere kreative und kuriose klima rettende projekte gibt es jetzt hier bei den science fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir reden ja hier immer wieder mal über den klimawandel und seine folgen natürlich ist es längst überfällig
Dass jeder einzelne mithilft die globale menschengemachte erwärmung zu stoppen oder zumindest zu verlangsamen und wenn wir mal ehrlich sind ist
das doch
im alltag echt leicht umzusetzen fahrrad oder zumindest bus fahren oder bahn fahren statt das auto zu benutzen zum beispiel
Im großen stil müssten die erneuerbaren energie gefördert werden und so weiter und so fort einige von euch
Können diese ganzen dinge zum klima retten aber vielleicht nicht mehr hören ja da verstehe ich aber ich habe. Jetzt was für euch denn
forschungsteams weltweit haben auch noch andere
Wirklich sehr ausgefallene und kuriose ideen um den klimawandel, zu stoppen die top-vier
Abgefahrensten ideen gegen den klimawandel jetzt bei klicks und science fiction auf der vier weiße straßen und städte die erste idee kommt aus den usa
der aktuelle präsident donald trump hat ja mal gesagt der
klimawandel sei eine erfindung der chinesen wir wissen alle dass er nicht wirklich ein vorreiter in sachen klimapolitik ist
Andere amerikanische politiker dafür aber umso mehr sie wollen die klimaziele wie geplant umsetzen so zum beispiel
Los angeles die stadt hat ein riesiges hitzeproblem
temperaturen von mehr als 35 grad sind genauso wie hitze tote keine seltenheit der bürgermeister von
Los angeles kurz abgekürzt hat deswegen jetzt eine maßnahme gegen den klimawandel beschlossen die auf den ersten blick erstmal ziemlich
kurios klingt einige straßen der stadt werden mit einem hellen kühlen belag
asphaltiert das komplette stadtbild von los angeles wird sich dadurch verändern
Konkret wird eine spezialfarbe zum einsatz kommen die in der lage ist den asphalt um 7 grad herunterzukühlen ursprünglich
entwickelt wurde diese falle namens cool ziel
militärfahrzeugen die dadurch während ihrer wartezeiten heruntergekühlt werden konnten dadurch waren sie besser getarnt und konnten auch durch
infrarot kameras nicht vom feind entdeckt werden und kohl ziel
Soll nicht nur die straßen abkühlen sondern auch einen anderen positiven effekt mit sich bringen auch die
klimaanlagen sollen dadurch weniger laufen eine kuriose aber
Effektive idee im herbst wird die farbe nun in einigen bezirken der stadt getestet mal sehen ob es sich durchsetzen
dennoch ist das ein wirklich teures projekt pro kilometer straße
kostet das ganze rund
40.000 dollar weiter gedacht könnte es aber zukünftig ganze städte in weiß oder
Hellen farben wie beige geben nicht nur weiße straßen sondern auch weiße dächer und häuser sie würden das sonnenlicht dann ins all
reflektieren ganz nach dem vorbild vieler dörfer in nordafrika oder südeuropa
Deren häuser selbst bei der größten hitze kühl bleibt die drei
künstlicher vulkan ausbruch schwefel wolken in der atmosphäre wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber berichtet heftige vulkanausbrüche
können letztendlich dafür sorgen dass sich der himmel verdunkelt viele millionen tonnen schwefel werden bei einem ausbruch in die atmosphäre geschleudert
17 millionen tonnen waren es zum beispiel beim ausbruch des pinatubo auf den philippinen
im jahr 1991 auch damals
verdunkelten die kleinen schwefelsäure tröpfchen in der atmosphäre den himmel die temperatur damals sank weltweit um
0,5 grad es gibt tatsächlich überlegungen solch einen ausbruch
künstlich nachzuahmen diese ideen kommen aus dem bereich des sogenannten
geoengineering oder auch climate engineering genannt damit sind gezielte eingriffe in das
weltweite klimageschehen gemeint also grob gesagt mit hightech gegen den klimawandel denn wenn
Schwefeldioxid im großen maßstab in die stratosphäre gesprüht wird gebe es wohl einen ähnlichen effekt wie bei einem großen
vulkanausbruch das sonnenlicht würde durch die schwefelpartikel ins weltall
Reflektiert auf der erde würde es kühler werden eine ähnliche idee kommt von einem. Chemie nobelpreisträger demnach sollen
spezialflugzeuge oder heißluftballons in einer
höhe von 15 bis 20 kilometern feine schwefelpartikel
versprühen seiner rechnung nach ließe sich die temperatur auf der erde dadurch um bis zu 25 grad bis zum jahr
2100 senken und diese idee war nicht ganz neu den schon in den 80er jahren gab es ein klimaforscher der auch
Schwefeldioxid als lösungsvorschlag. Im kampf gegen den klimawandel
vorgeschlagen hatte doch die nachteile sind gravierend denn der schwefel in der atmosphäre
Würde wohl nicht nur das klima abkühlen er würde auch die ozonschicht
zerstören forschungsteams weltweit denken deshalb jetzt über andere aerosole nach
Mit denen solche ideen umsetzbar werden und auf der zwei sonnenschirme
Im weltall ganz ohne chemie kommt sie die idee eines astronomenteams der university of arizona
Aus auch sie beschäftigen sich mit dem geo engineering und wollen den
Klimawandel auf der erde bekämpfen indem sie zwischen der sonne und der erde zu etwas ausspannen wie einen
gigantischen sonnenschirm konkret schlagen sie
siliziumscheiben vor die die einstrahlung der sonne um knapp zwei prozent reduzieren sollen 16 millionen dünne siliziumscheiben
müssten davon mit hilfe elektromagnetischer
Kanonen ins all geschossen werden an dem punkt wo sich die anziehungskraft von erde und sonne aufhebt
Da würden sie sich dann auf rein und eine art sonnensegel bilden
Doch diese idee steckt noch in den kinderschuhen zum einen wäre das natürlich mit gigantischen kosten verbunden zum anderen sind die risiken abzuwägen
modellrechnung sagen voraus dass sich die tropen solch ein projekt abkühlen könnten arktis und antarktis könnten dagegen
trotzdem wärmer werden und auf der einst
künstliche bäume pflanzen mit bäumen das klima retten das prinzip dahinter hat sich ja jeder schon einmal gehört wälder nehmen über die bäume
Kohlendioxid aus der luft auf sie fixieren es
Im holz so sinkt der co2 gehalt in der atmosphäre und die erderwärmung wird gebremst und so heißt es immer wieder das große
Flächen aufgeforstet werden müssen doch der nachteil liegt auf der hand es sind immense flächen die gebraucht würden und zudem würde es jahrzehnte dauern bis
Es etwas nutzt deswegen gibt es, im kontext geoengineering auch allerhand ideen künstliche bäume
zu pflanzen bäume aus stein könnten beispielsweise
Nach dem sogenannten er capture verfahren co2 aus der atmosphäre holen das co2 würde hierbei
unterirdisch gelagert werden doch die technik ist teuer und noch nicht wirklich effektiv
Dennoch ist es ziemlich aufwendig das co2 aus der atmosphäre
Zu holen ja das waren jetzt also die top-vier kuriosen ideen zum kampf gegen den klimawandel
Doch was das geo-engineering betrifft. Da halten es die meisten wissenschaftlerinnen und wissen
und auch regierungschef dieser erde für zu früh solche technik tatsächlich umzusetzen
sie seien zu wenig erforscht und die auswirkungen
zu krass dennoch steht auch fest dass solche ideen nicht gleich von vornherein als mittel gegen die schlimmsten folgen der globalen erwärmung
Auszuschließen sind ja und hier bei pixum halte ich euch natürlich
Dazu auf dem laufenden wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke ja hier geht es weiter
Mit klimawandel bewiesen skeptiker endgültig widerlegt ja sehr spannendes video mit allen wichtigen
argumenten also nicht verpassen und draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran